une production du studio SF
bienvenue sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter date
site pH Quentin avec moi Dom plante
cette semaine de quoi est-ce qu'on part
cette semaine on parle de transport avec
Fanny Tremblay rascicaut qui est
professeur à l'École nationale
d'administration publique puis qu'une
experte en transport puis en
développement
urbain en fait c'était vraiment
fascinant en fait j'ai écrit directement
après l'annonce du gouvernement
sur le nouveau troisième lien le
changement de plan en termes de
troisième lien quand même un débat de
société au Québec important un projet
majeur puis
c'est quelqu'un qui s'adresse souvent
aux médiocres qui dit vraiment quatre
chemins pour dire qu'est-ce qu'elle
pense de différents projets puis
évidemment son opinion est toujours basé
sur son expertise sur la science donc
c'est super
c'est pas intéressant en fait de d'avoir
son opinion sur sur ce projet-là entre
autres mais sur d'autres projets dans
d'autres villes qui ont fonctionné sur
aussi la réalité à Montréal sur
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire plus
largement au niveau du Québec
quels sont les solutions en fait sur
sur le transport en fait juste dans le
futur puis tout ça avec des pointes
d'humour et de légèreté qui était
vraiment super le fun et c'est vraiment
une super cool fille enfin qui était
avant le fun
on se demande
souvent
dans le podcast on rencontre des experts
qui parlent de X ou Y sujet puis on
dirait qu'on est comme vraiment tout le
temps à genre un moment charnière dans
dans la direction vers laquelle on va se
diriger en tant que société
que ce soit pour l'intelligence
artificielle pour les transports pour la
lutte aux changements climatique comme
Émile Roy nous avait dit le long terme
et puis on dirait qu'on est encore plus
là en ce moment on est quand même à
mi-chemin entre on est au y entre une
utopie une dystopie puis vous allez voir
on en parle un petit peu justement dans
le podcast fait écouter sans plus
attendre bonne écoute bon podcast le
podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par nos amis mannequin
[Musique]
qui nous ont demandé de le dire comme ça
mon nouveau goûtu pour la barbe et on
leur Verde Edge ici que ça c'est leur
nouveau leur nouvelle tondeuse
électrique pour la barbe puis
[Musique]
toute ma vie ça c'est de loin le
meilleur et le plus le plus utile puis
non seulement les clés est incroyable
mais ça vient tout un kit pour avoir la
barbe idéale la barbe parfaite qui sent
bon qui est bien taillé qui est bien
soigné qui est bien huilé dans le fond
là il y a même si c'est top semaine
détaillée ici les 6 étapes facile pour
avoir une barbe incroyable on a du
shampoing revitalisant le ping après son
porte la tondeuse on finit au ciseau on
a une petite brosse et on se met une
petite tuile pour qu'elle soit bien bien
nourri et c'est vraiment après ça votre
barbe
la meilleure base non seulement si vous
avez une barbe c'est de la bombe mais si
vous dettez quelqu'un qui a une barre
moi ma blonde elle me dit que depuis
que j'utilise les produits que je fais
la routine et je pique moins je suis
doux c'est beaucoup plus fun d'embrasser
fait que utiliser un code promo sans
filtre pour 20% de rabais et la
livraison gratuite assurez-vous
d'utiliser le code pour dire que nous
vous envoient ça nous aide ça les aide
ça va être tout le monde puis merci
manucate oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
Québec Montréal parce que moi j'habite à
Québec aussi ok
j'ai commencé un peu en tabarnak le
podcast parce que
mon expérience avait été misérable tu
sais ça a tellement coûté cher ça a
tellement été long puis j'avais aucun
contrôle sur comme mes allées venu ton
expérience de train et comment mais je
dirais que ça dépend des fois mais cette
fois-ci ça a bien été il faut savoir
faut savoir qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
est-ce qu'on veut atteindre Montréal le
plus rapidement possible on va atteindre
Montréal en travaillant moi j'avais du
travail à faire hier heureusement la
connexion était bonne heureusement mon
ordi a pas buggé donc non ça s'est super
bien passé j'ai pu ketchup on work
une bonne expérience et pourquoi que on
choisirait le train ou plutôt que
l'autobus pour le confort
c'est vraiment intéressant moi avant
quelques mois là chaque fois que je
faisais Québec Montréal c'était en bus
parce que ça prend deux heures et demie
puis il y a vraiment plus d'orage c'est
vraiment rapide le thé Sainte-Foy
c'est des fois c'est deux heures et demi
le soir là donc quand je voulais un
horaire flexible quand j'étais au
postdoc quand à Lucam je faisais Québec
Montréal en bus parce que l'arrêt était
juste à côté de l'UQAM puis du métro et
tout ça mais maintenant depuis que je me
suis habitué à travailler sur la route
parce que je travaille pas maintenant je
travaille sur la route fait que je
préfère les trains de via où je suis
plus
confortable pour travailler puis tu sais
quand je fais des longs déplacements en
classe à faire je vais pas faire de pub
mais c'est quand même un repas fait que
ton père dit aime tu étais
c'est parfois économe de prendre la
classe à faire travailler puis manger
que que je sois tant mieux se perdre ton
temps donc ça dépend vraiment qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire là je suis en train de
passer mon permis de conduire
[Rires]
moi on dirait que le permis de conduire
c'est comme je sais pas les gens qu'on
était quand on attendait d'avoir 16 ans
la journée de ta faute
je me fais tellement écoré par j'ai pas
mon permis je veux terre mais mais c'est
des tracteurs
pour ceux qui connaissent la ville de
Québec en hiver ensuite Saint-Charles
j'ai commencé à voyager j'ai eu une
bourse dans le fond pour
université de Toronto pendant un an que
mon bac que j'ai fait un an à
l'Université de Toronto ensuite j'ai
fait entre le bac et la maîtrise j'ai
fait un en Taïwan pour apprendre le
mandarin ouais
vraiment puis les gens papa anglais
quasiment là-bas donc c'est vraiment
une bonne barrière les nightmarket était
absolument incroyable comme expérience
mais on avait vraiment l'impression à
l'intérieur même de 300 km d'être à des
endroits complètement différents
métropole asiatique super
c'est beaucoup de bruit beaucoup de
mouvement
sur la côte Est dans un petit village
puis là c'est comme fait full beau gros
soleil des plages surfers
tellement j'ai entendu tellement de bien
là je suis allé dans les montagnes mais
j'ai pas j'ai pas traversé par train
parce que il y a un TGV dans le fond où
l'équivalent de TGV il y a un train qui
fait vraiment toute la la mais toute la
l'île ensemble et puis on était remonté
par là mais par la couronne
ça ça avait l'air vraiment d'une place
genre dans dans le sud de vacances
on a arrêté d'un peu d'un petit village
si on arrive au sud première montée par
la côte ouest mais vraiment plus
rapidement là où est-ce que c'est plus
peuplé plus les grandes villes
là-bas puis il y a beaucoup de nous on a
voté des places où c'est du tourisme
écologique aussi donc c'est vraiment si
on veut être dépaysé
de jeune puis genre tout le monde était
dans leur fenêtre regardez comme si on
était des extraterrestres j'avais les
cheveux rouges en plus
en quelle année
2016 ok
on avait trouvé un espèce de dire
l'incroyable c'était genre 580 pièces
le voyagement était un enfer
parce que genre c'était pour ça que
c'était pas cher c'est que c'était comme
5 avions différents que il faut que tu
changes d'aéroport à New York mais en
tout cas bref
un petit peu d'argent tu fais plus ce
genre de trajet le mieux
il y a un temps pour fake dans le fond
j'ai fait ça c'est en 2006 où j'ai
appelé là-bas pendant 1 an
c'était là-bas tu allais apprendre le
mandarin et puis qu'est-ce que tu allais
étudier là-bas j'étais inscrite dans le
fond dans les cours où dans des cours
mettons business classiste mais j'étais
vraiment là pour apprendre le mandarin
il y a le gouvernement chinois qui a ce
programme de bourse là pour les
étrangers pour les étudiants canadiens
c'est le programme de bourse chinoise
puis moi j'avais seulement eu la bourse
partielle parce que ça s'en vient
vraiment compétitif à avoir ces bourses
là puis vu que je voulais pas m'endetter
ou peu importe je l'avais décliné parce
que c'est seulement partielle puis
quelques mois plus tard Taïwan il y
avait eu un programme pilote on avait
seulement été deux de l'Université Laval
à être sélectionné j'avais la bourse
complète avec une collègue puis
donc c'est ça puis moi dans le fond mon
objectif pour avoir une bourse complète
aux États-Unis pour faire son doctorat
il faut parler trois langues vous parlez
sa langue maternelle vous parlez
l'anglais faut parler une troisième
langue puis moi je suis pas quelqu'un
qui est très bon dans les langues donc
j'ai décidé que ma troisième langue
s'arrête le mandarin pour avoir un
avantage comparatif sur ceux que c'est
l'espagnol puis en plus la prochaine la
grande puissance et la Chine
tu vas prendre quelque chose de
d'accessible
par rapport leur langue ils te
respectent pas tant pis c'est comme la
sainte interdit c'est interdit aux
étrangers pour vraiment bien comprendre
la culture chinoise pour un peu parler
la langue parce qu'ils ont vraiment une
structure de pensée différente de la
nôtre donc c'était ça l'objectif c'est
d'aller d'apprendre le mandarin un an
là-bas pour pouvoir avoir une bourse
complète pour faire mon dock aux
États-Unis effectivement le
sauter à travers les anneaux pour
atteindre l'objectif c'est que là je
vais de ça non non après ça je revenais
à Québec je finis ma maîtrise puis après
ça j'ai été j'ai eu la bourse complète
pour tempo University pour faire mon
dock puis j'ai fait 4 ans Delphi j'ai
fait ma cinquième année en rédaction au
Québec après ce Montréal pour le poste
doc puis j'ai eu mon poste de profs
Québec c'était quoi le sujet de ton doc
qui est postdock mettons le sujet de mon
doctorat dans le fond c'est la manière
dont les réformes institutionnelles au
palier régional peuvent faciliter
l'intégration des transports puis
l'aménagement du territoire donc j'ai
sélectionné deux villes Toronto Chicago
Toronto Chicago en 2005-2016 toutes les
deux ont adopté leur gouvernement
provincial respectif là donc l'état de
l'Illinois puis le gouvernement de
l'Ontario au même moment ils ont adopté
des réformes au niveau régional pour
intégrer les transports puis
l'aménagement du territoire c'est worlds
ces deux réformes de nature opposées
donc à Chicago et ont fusionné l'agence
de planification des transports puis
l'agence de planification de
l'aménagement du territoire donc plus
une réforme horizontale fonctionnelle
puis à Toronto mais là c'est le
gouvernement de l'Ontario que vraiment
mis en oeuvre une réforme verticale qui
a imposé un plan de gestion de la
croissance qui a imposer une ceinture
verte qui a créé métrolinks son agence
de transport qui est beaucoup plus Top
Down c'est que j'ai regardé j'ai fait
une étude longitudinale 10 ans après
quels étaient l'impact de ces
réformes-là sur le processus de
planification au niveau régional sur le
choix d'investissement transport puis
sur l'occupation du sol l'aménagement du
territoire donc c'était ce sur quoi
porter mental c'est que je m'intéresse
dans le fond aux questions
mon grand objectif c'est la diminution
des GS qui proviennent des transports au
niveau régional mais l'aménagement du
territoire c'est vraiment un intrant
c'est un déterminant des choix de mode
et tout ça donc comment on fait pour
municipal de gouvernement c'est
considéré juste comme un palier
administratif parce que au Canada par
exemple
les municipalités sont des créatures des
provinces c'est un palier
administratives pour la provision de
service
des matières résiduelles le service à la
propriété c'est les municipalités
exécutent les plans des paliers
supérieurs maintenant il y a comme une
transformation de la chose municipale
maintenant ça le gouvernement de
proximité et tout ça mais historiquement
en sciences politiques
le palier municipal c'est pas considéré
comme étant un palais de gouvernement en
soi c'est toujours négligé c'est qu'on
le voit aujourd'hui dans les médias et
tout ça dans l'actualité c'est un palier
de gouvernement qui appelait à prendre
de plus en plus d'importance puis être
avoir un rôle central dans les affaires
publiques donc moi c'est pour ça j'ai
fait je voulais avoir une scolarité du
genre des cours spécialisés on a affaire
municipale c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
un dock en études urbaine
ces deux études de colocs que tu
mentionnais le Chicago petoronto
qu'est-ce qu'un inter-sortie
[Rires]
la plus grande c'est vraiment compliqué
mais pour faire simple quand il y a une
réforme
il y a des nouvelles ressources ça
brasse les cartes faites du côté du
processus de planification s'il y a des
améliorations il y a davantage de
ressources qui sont octroyées au
processus de planification régionale il
y a des plans qui sont développés il y a
des processus de consultation il y a des
ressources en planification qui sont
octroyales à nouvel agence parfois il y
a des pertes d'expertise mais ça dépend
comment tu fais ta réforme
tu peux donner davantage de pouvoir un
nouvel agence où tu peux créer une
nouvelle agence de toutes pièces il va y
avoir une différence mais il peut y
avoir davantage de capacités financières
de ressources humaines techniques pour
le processus de planification quand il y
a une réforme
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle maintenant du
côté des transports
lorsque c'est le gouvernement provincial
ou le gouvernement de l'État qui
contrôle les ressources puis qui
contrôlent quel projet sont financés
c'est des projets qui
qui ne représentent pas un optimum tu
sais ce sont des projets qui répondent à
des considérations politiques fait
commencer de transport c'est préférable
que les projets soient identifiés
priorisés par les agences de
planification de transport et par les
maires et mariches mais regroupés au
niveau régional pour développer un plan
qui fait du sens un consensus
donc pas les intérêts de certaines
villes mais avoir développé un plan
régional par les agences de transport
qui ont toute l'expertise les
connaissances puis les maires et mes
rêves qui connaissent là où on veut
développer le territoire sur le qui
connaissent aussi parce que c'est pas
juste une question de tracer une ligne
sur une carte un plan de transport il y
a des gens qui habitent là il y a des
populations qui ont besoin
la table lorsque le réseau express la
capitale a été annoncé parce qu'il
fallait que fasse une marchandage pour
son tramway mais il y a quand même
produit des études qui démontraient que
s'il y avait un troisième lien à faire
il devrait être à l'ouest parce que 80
70 à 80 % de la circulation des origines
destination se fait à l'ouest donc il y
a produit des données pour démontrer que
le troisième lien devrait pas se faire à
l'est ou de centre-ville à centre-ville
mais politiquement il doit ménager ses
relations fait que oui c'est sûr que
c'est préférable que ce soit les mers et
ma s au niveau régional qui a un
consensus qui soit déterminé avec les
agences de transport mais il faut aussi
qui est des critères qui proviennent des
paliers de gouvernement supérieur comme
aux États-Unis chose qu'on a au Québec
des critères du genre il faut qu'il y
ait un plan de transport régional sur 25
ans qui soit développé avec les citoyens
il faut qu'il y ait un plan
d'investissement quinquennal qui
respecte la contrainte budgétaire il
faut que l'ensemble des parties
prenantes soient autour de la table donc
il faut qu'il y ait des critères de
financement mais le fédéral l'ont un peu
avec les programmes d'investissement dit
ah on a plus de fond nous pour le
l'accroissement de la capacité routière
on a juste des financement pour pour le
transport collectif donc ça ça en est
une forme de critères mais vous voyez ce
que je veux dire donc le transport donc
il faut que ce soit planifié au niveau
local et au niveau de l'aménagement du
territoire par contre
selon mes recherches je pense que c'est
préférable qui est des critères qui
proviennent du palier provincial pour
parce que les mères et marais ont pas
l'intérêt de ne pas développer leur
territoire
donc c'est leur intérêt de toujours
développer à cause de la manière dont la
fiscalité est faite donc comme par
exemple le modèle ontarien avec la
ceinture de verdure mais ça c'est pas
les mères ensemble qui vont décider
qu'il va y avoir une ceinture de verdure
autour de Toronto autour de Montréal
faut que ça soit les paliers supérieurs
qui interviennent puis qui imposent des
critères
finalement mais c'est la fiscalité on ne
peut ignorer la fiscalité une toute
réforme au niveau régional qui vise
l'interaction des transports
d'aménagement du territoire puis le
développement urbain durable qui
ignorent fiscalité et voir l'échec parce
que c'est le déterminant des des
intérêts des acteurs au palier le cas
puis mettons pour clore mettons le
dossier de des sujets de tes études pour
parler de précisément du contexte si
mais dirais-tu mettons que selon ton
expertise que les deux côtés étudiés
ton objectif étant le tantôt de la
diminution des GS est-ce que ça a été un
succès finalement c'est vraiment une
bonne question dans le fond
quand est venu le moment de d'étudier
l'impact sur l'aménagement du territoire
ou l'occupation du sol qui est un
déterminant des des choix de transport
10 ans c'était pas assez pour constater
les effets très difficiles à mesurer
c'est très difficile de faire le lien
causé à l'encre la réforme la
densification les choix de mode les
investissements ça s'observe vraiment
sur le long terme
donc non j'ai pas réussi à observer une
démission des vieillesse qui proviennent
des transports si on est vraiment comme
en amont des choix puis des effets
par contre le cotisateur qui est un
qu'on a étudié avec une équipe de
recherche qui a été pilotée par Jean
merci j'ai travaillé avec ce qui est
cette équipe de recherche en presque 10
ans on étudier les instruments de
politique publique donc les instruments
c'est les méthodes de mise en oeuvre des
politiques donc
la carotte le bâton l'information c'est
les mesures incitatives les mesures
dyspasives la sensibilisation la
gouvernance tout ça puis on étudie les
villes américaines d'Amérique sécuritiba
au Brésil
Seattle Toronto Chicago Boston Montréal
toutes des villes qui ont des bonnes
parts modales pour les transports
collectifs puis on a regardé quelles
instruments les différents paliers de
gouvernement avaient mis en oeuvre pour
atteindre ses résultats là dans le cas
de Seattle on a eu des on a observé des
des le choix d'instruments qui ont fait
en sorte qu'il y a seulement 25% des
gens qui prennent leur auto pour aller
travailler au centre-ville le matin donc
une combinaison d'instruments qui s'est
déployé sur genre 30 ans qui a commencé
dans les années 90 puis que là
aujourd'hui on voit les effets je l'ai
pas observé dans ma thèse mais je l'ai
observé j'ai pu observer les effets des
certains instruments et de
réformes combinaison d'instruments qui
ont mené à un bon résultat puis
là tu dis 25%
utilise la voiture seront au travail
c'est à toi juste à titre indicatif on
est où nous ici mettons Montréal et
Québec Montréal centre-ville Montréal
centre-ville de mémoire
c'est 50% des gens qui prennent les
transports collectifs et actifs dans le
centre-ville de Montréal pour se
déplacer le matin il fait que ça c'est
des super bonnes par modèle
[Rires]
dans le fond ça commence à 91 avec un
plan de gestion de la croissance donc on
a imposé aux villes de densifier donc la
ville de Seat le fait des urban village
l'équivalent de la ville le 15 minutes
l'équivalent des tas donc vraiment la
densification autour
pardon autour des points de transport
collectifs
qu'on revient tout à l'heure sur ces
concepts parce que ça m'intéresse la
ville de 15 minutes même si est
conceptuellement on en entendu parler
des jeux mais plus tard on y revient la
même chose l'état de la ville de 15
minutes les urban village le New
airbanes c'est toute la même chose c'est
juste des mots différents
donc densité mixité un design pour la
marche habilité puis l'utilisation du
vélo la distance des transports
collectifs puis la
l'accès à la destination
donc il faut qu'il y ait du transport
collectif également mais il y a
plusieurs autres dés qui se rajoutent là
puis idéalement
l'approche de la mobilité durable du
gouvernement du Québec s'est basé sur
une approche internationale qui
s'appelle RTA réduire transférer puis
améliorer réduire c'est réduire la
demande en déplacement puis comment tu
réduit ta demande en déplacement mais
c'est par l'aménagement du territoire
beaucoup donc résoudre la fréquence de
déplacement les réduire la durée du
déplacement c'est ça la ville de 15
minutes c'est que tout à proximité
supposons moi j'habite à côté de la rue
quartier à Québec j'ai tout
c'est même pas 15 minutes c'est genre 5
minutes donc puis l'ENAP est à 15
minutes à pied c'est ça la ville de 15
minutes c'est que j'ai pas besoin d'auto
j'ai pas besoin de voiture j'ai pas
besoin de mon permis arrêtez de
m'énerver
toute le développement immobilier c'est
l'aménagement du territoire fait pour
revenir à Seattle
exactement ensuite ils oublient je les
grands employeurs à avoir des plantes de
gestion des déplacements de leurs
employés donc prévoir regarder les
employeurs les grands employeurs de plus
de 100 employés
de d'avoir des
comment dire des études des enquêtes sur
les déplacements de leurs employés
d'atteindre des objectifs et tout ça dès
les années 90 ensuite
mais ça progressivement ça s'est
développé cette politique là donc c'est
une combinaison donc de 1 tu as
l'aménagement du territoire de deux
tunnels fardeau sur les employeurs de
trois toutes tes investissements
transports collectif tu les passes par
des référendums donc au niveau
régional au niveau de la municipalité
tous les investissements en transport
collectif il se finance des des plantes
transports avec on va augmenter la taxe
de vente de temps on a créé des finances
de Swix où on prélève une taxe de vente
supplémentaire on va augmenter vos taxes
foncières de quelques points on va aller
chercher tant et tant de subventions
avec un plan de transport avec un plan
de financier qui est cohérent puis fait
voter ça parce qu'on la culture des
référendums là-bas parce qu'il y a des
élections et des propositions c'est
propositions proposition proposition
puis fait qu'ils ont pu avec cette ce
mécanisme là investir massivement dans
le transport collectif aussi donc vous
voyez l'aménagement du territoire il y a
le transport collectif puis entre les
deux il y a les politiques qui visent
les employeurs puis maintenant ça s'est
développé aujourd'hui là tu travailles
pour n'importe quel grand employeur à
Seattle dont laissé passer de transport
en commun qui est payé par l'employeur
parce que les plans de c'est ce que je
mets de l'avant aussi au Québec Montréal
puis à Québec aussi là si on pense à
l'augmentation de la capacité si on veut
ramener les gens dans le transport
collectif puis résoudre le financement
de l'exploitation parce que du
financement pour les infrastructures
mais après ça on laisse les villes
s'arranger avec l'exploitation déficites
à Montréal de 500 millions de dollars
pour la RTM mais ça passe par les
employeurs avec les plans de réduction
du navetage ça ça peut être implanté
soit par les villes ça peut être
implanté par le gouvernement provincial
qui impose au grand employeur ou même
par le gouvernement fédéral moi je l'ai
recommandé au gouvernement fédéral
évidemment personne n'écoute mais c'est
pas grave au moins je l'ai dit plus
savent pas dire qu'il savait pas
c'est que tu oublies les employeurs
doivent développer un plan de réduction
du navetage en choisissant dans le fond
des deux mesures parmi trois grandes
catégories de mesures faites des
catégories de mesures c'est
l'information et l'équipement avoir des
douches des supports à vélo dans dans
l'édifice avoir le des applications pour
le covoiturage et tout ça donc
l'équipement l'information ensuite les
subventions beaucoup d'employeurs
financent le transport collectif à leurs
employés puis ils payent dans le fond
des banques pas assez au prix du gros ça
fait en sorte que 40 à 60% des revenus
d'exploitation des sociétés de transport
sont payées par les employeurs
mais c'est pas gratuit c'est payé par
l'employeur moins cher fait que vous
voyez le cercle vertu dans le fond puis
là tu parles des grandes entreprises ces
métaux d'entreprises qui ont eu sans
employés c'est pratiquement des peanuts
payer
payés ça au prix au prix du bac à ses
employés là revient vraiment pas cher
pour une entreprise qui a des roulements
aussi gros que ça le tu sais
puis
maintenant il y a aussi des il y a aussi
des programmes qui ont été développés
pour des pour des compagnies de cinq
employés et plus des compagnies de moins
de cinq employés parce qu'il y a aussi
la ville de Seattle que ses propres
programmes c'est pas les grands
employeurs c'est les propriétaires
d'édifices qui doivent avoir des
programmes de réduction
fait que ça donc je reviens juste pour
les réseaux sociaux
fait que des fois c'est parfois quand il
y a pas le service de transport
collectif ça va être des navettes pour
les employeurs puis le troisième
c'est le stationnement parce que le
stationnement c'est le grand déterminant
du choix de mode d'un individu si le
stationnement destination la personne
doit prendre sa voiture point
donc
gestion bonne gestion du stationnement
donc ça ça fait en sorte ça fait le
cercle vertueux c'est comme ça qu'on
réussit un mélangement du territoire
investissement transport avec les
référendum programme de résolution du
navetage plus j'ai une question pour
vous qu'est-ce
il est où le problème
quelque chose
il y a quelque chose qui a commencé
c'est une bonne question moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que le problème c'est
que
c'est plus plus ça va bien moins il y a
de voiture plus le monde veut le prendre
en voiture oui ça c'est vrai
non dans le fond c'est le logement
bordables ok
comme Vancouver ils ont oublié de
protéger les
le logement abordable donc les gens ont
pas le choix de s'éloigner donc de faire
plus de placement
c'est c'est l'offre et la demande le
marché immobilier tu laisses aller puis
augmentent augmentent augmentent c'est
qu'il faut l'intervention des pouvoirs
publics pour corriger ces effets de
marché là puis ça c'est mon un des
sujets de recherche auquel je
m'intéresse en ce moment c'est
l'abordabilité des Todd
Beatles le développement immobilier le
long des cordes de transport collectif
comment tu fais pour garantir la
bordabilité
parce que les prix du foncier sont
vraiment plus élevés
naturellement parce que c'est proche des
transports collectifs puis une demande
de personnes demandent l'attentes donc
les gens ils veulent habiter proche des
transports collectifs mais il y a pas
assez de logement avec les prix du
foncier sont vraiment plus élevés puis
c'est une question de
c'est une question d'équité d'accès aux
transports collectif parce que c'est ta
population qui est dépendante des
transports collectifs il y a pas accès
donc je regarde ça c'est mon c'est
financé par le frqst le fond de
recherche québécoise société culture
je regarde ça à Québec Montréal
Calgary Toronto Vancouver un restaurant
à faire
donc puis les études qui démontrent
c'est que si tu as des
immeubles au prix du marché le long des
transports collectifs dans l'état tu vas
avoir plus de transfert modal
parce que les gens ils vont délaisser la
voiture mais si tu as du logement social
abordable tu as plus d'achat landage
fait qu'il faut que parce que les gens
qui utilisent déjà le transport
collectif l'utilise encore davantage
c'est qu'il faut avoir faut prendre ça
en compte dans la prise de décision on
fait que si tu veux favoriser la
chalandage d'une ligne par exemple ben
c'est là que tu mets ton ton logement
social abordable mais si tu veux avoir
un plus grand transfert moderne le tu
peux avoir
des logements davantage auprès du marché
puis les avoir un certain laissez faire
mais il faut en prendre en compte parce
que c'est une question d'équité d'accès
si on parle maintenant des sujets qui
pour lequel je t'écris à la base
je t'ai écrit je pense au lendemain en
tout cas après l'annonce le gouvernement
que leur projet de 3e lien dans sa forme
qui est
avec des chars qui passent on
abandonnait ça puis pour un autre projet
qui serait de transport en commun
seulement
selon toi mettons est-ce que le projet
dans sa forme d'avant était un bon
projet
en anglais là c'est vraiment un projet
faire unique qui fait aucun sens qui
continue à aller de l'avant à cause de
de
considérations politiques de préférence
puis pour quelle raison ce n'est pas la
route en fait
pour quelle raison ça tenait la route
non
si tu veux résoudre la congestion tu
peux pas augmenter ta capacité routière
à cause de la demande induites
parce que supposons une route et
congestionnée
donc ce que tu vas faire tu vas ajouter
une voix à acheter une voix acheter une
voix puis le hop
350 10 ans plus tard ben c'est les mêmes
niveaux de congestion pourquoi mais
c'est à cause de la demande induite la
demande indique c'est que à court terme
ça réduit des temps de déplacement donc
les gens ils voyagent plus et puis
lorsqu'on regarde vraiment au niveau
plus granulaire le doux provient cette
demande là c'est de 1 c'est
l'augmentation du camionnage parce que
les entreprises qui manufacture des
biens lourds vont s'installer proche des
nouveaux segments autoroutiers pour
faciliter le camionnage ensuite
les gens changent de mode donc s'il
prenaient le transport collectif ils
vont prendre
ils vont revenir à la voiture puis ils
vont voyager plus tout simplement
changer de mode changer d'horaire
voyager plus puis aussi l'étalement
urbain puis
l'autre facteur c'est le détournement
d'autres voix aussi moi je prenais cet
itinéraire là je vais changer
d'itinéraire donc là les textos c'est il
y a personne la loi fondamentale de la
congestion autoroutière la loi
fondamentale de la congestion routière
ça a été testé partout il y a très peu
de loi en sciences sociales mais en fait
c'est même pas une séance sociale c'est
de l'ingénierie c'est quasiment
mathématique puis ils ont testé ça
partout plusieurs conditions différents
prix de l'essence
c'est pas mal toujours le même résultat
toujours la même résultats
ouais absolument
dans le fond l'état de la science à cet
égard là c'est maintenant la demande
réduite parce que l'inverse est aussi
vrai quand tu envoies quand tu enlèves
une voie de circulation
tu as du trafic évaporé fait que ou
pourquoi ou parce que comme le tunnel
lui Hippolyte la fontaine quand il est
fermé là
les gens pensaient que ça allait être
l'hécatombe totale puis finalement hop
ça c'est juste c'est
aussi
dedans genre
en plein heure de trafic puis c'est
aussi long qu'avant
particulier vraiment particulier fait
que les études en ce moment essaie de
voir où va ce trafic et va porter
évaporez-le parce qu'il y a une
réduction de d'environ 20% en moyenne ou
la médiane de réduction du trafic quand
on lève des voix même chose quand ils
ont enlevé une voix sur le Pont Pierre
la porte l'été dernier à Québec il y
avait prévu des hôtels pour les
résidents et tout ça ils ont vraiment
adopté des mesures de
des solutions c'est comme si tout d'un
coup il y en avait plein d'habitants on
met des navettes les transports en
commun moins cher si ce si c'est ça
c'est dans le fond on le sait quoi faire
finalement pour pour régler les
problèmes mais pourquoi qu'on on déploie
juste ceux qui a une urgence pourquoi
que c'est pourquoi qu'on instaure pas
tout le temps ça finalement seulement ce
sont des choix politiques mais je pense
que c'est le syndrome de la grenouille
dans l'eau bouillante là avant mourir
le syndrome de la grenouille dans l'eau
bouillante elle va mourir
c'est quoi cette expression là mais je
comprends
pas c'est très chaud tranquillement la
grenouille elle fait juste rester là
puis assez bouillante avant de se rendre
compte
c'est une expression anglophone je pense
je sais pas d'où vient d'où vient cette
référence là je sais pas s'il y a ça
tout c'est à mort
[Rires]
ça finit toujours par nous
faites-le
troisième lien c'était pas une super
idée dès le départ c'est quand on fait
une historique du projet ça a été poussé
c'est la Chambre de commerce de les
vider les années 70 le
faisait la promotion du troisième lien
une nouvelle idée non non c'est dans les
plans les plans grébers des années 60 70
pas 60-70 50 des années 50
donc si c'est un désir les gens ils
prennent leur désir pour des besoins
c'est pas un besoin
ouais c'est ça parce qu'il y a une
différence en cam c'est vrai c'est même
moi habiter en Québec c'est vrai que ce
serait le fun d'aller à les vies genre
direct mais c'est pas un besoin
effectivement de toute façon c'est rare
que les gens il est très peu de gens de
Québec qui vont enlever non de
centre-ville à centre-ville
à Notre-Dame du portage et puis moi je
m'appelle gouvernement
des grandes tiges des grandes tiges pour
un ascenseur puis un pentas en haut de
toutes les affaires
puis le nouveau projet où on dirait un
Québec ça serait que le transport en
commun
est-ce que c'est plus intéressant est-ce
que c'est
le problème
mais est-ce que cette idée-là c'était
juste pour pas avoir l'air de
complètement revenir sur les paroles du
troisième lien et puis que ça arrivera
jamais ou c'est parce qu'effectivement
je suis comme toi j'ai moi il y a
personne que je connais qui est
intéressé par ce projet-là ça sonne
comme un genre de plan transitoire déjà
on veut pas dire qu'on a quand même mal
échappé fait qu'on va donner une genre
de solution
que qui intéresse personne c'est qu'on
va dire que ça ça existe plus mais la
personne va être vraiment fâché parce
que personne ne voulait vraiment
je pense que c'est ça aussi sauf que moi
j'aurais aimé ça que le gouvernement
reconnaisse
qu'on a besoin d'un plan de transport
régional qui soit basé sur les données
probantes puis qui est quand même
objectif la réduction des émissions
on va faire un plan régional qu'on
laisse tomber le frame aussi en même
temps
moi c'est ce que j'aurais mais je
comprends qu'il faut c'est pas c'est pas
simple possible mais tu es qu'on fait
quand on retrace l'historique du
troisième lien quand je disais personne
l'a demandé c'est que les palais de
gouvernement en 2000 quoi 2014 2015 je
connais sur qui allait peinturer le pont
de Québec puis là les radios ont puis la
Chambre de commerce de Lévis ont ramené
cette idée-là troisième lien et puis à
l'époque c'était le projet était évalué
à 500 millions de dollars c'est 10
milliards maintenant donc c'est vraiment
pas réaliste puis
donc voilà petit c'est basé sur l'idée
que
ça va réduire le temps de déplacement
entre les deux rives mais quand on sait
que l'augmentation de la capacité
routière ça résout pas le problème de la
congestion sur les pompes là on a amené
plein d'autres arguments la sécurité le
droit au déplacement le droit au
développement sur la Rive-Sud la dévie
qui va avoir un nouveau chantier donc on
essaie tout le temps de trouver des
arguments pour faire passer la couleur
remettre ici ça passe pas là c'est
difficilement réalisable donc je pense
qu'on a vraiment trompé la population on
a un sens parce que n'importe qui qui
connaît un peu la manière dont les
grands projets fonctionnent puis les
creuser en dessous du fleuve et tout ça
l'espèce de on va construire un
tunnelier pour construire le plus gros
tunnel au monde voyons c'est vraiment
prendre du membre des imbéciles non mais
c'est vrai
que ça c'est pas correct je pense de la
part de prendre les gens pour des il
faut jamais sous-estimer l'intelligence
de la population la population sur leur
explique qu'ils vont comprendre
en tous les cas donc même le nouveau
même le nouveau projet il peut réaliste
ouais je pense que oui je pense que oui
lorsque le
lorsque le bureau de projet du troisième
lien a été mis sur pied par le
gouvernement libéral il y avait cinq
scénarios donc un scénario qui était
la meilleure utilisation des ponts
actuels puis la gestion de la demande
puis d'autres scénarios le comme un au
centre
c'est quoi deux à l'ouest de à l'Est un
au centre puis lorsque le gouvernement
de la claque est rentré et on choisit
seulement les scénarios à l'Est puis on
délaissé dans le fond le bureau de
projet ne s'intéressait plus au scénario
d'utilisation des ponts actuels fait que
je pense que si la version si l'étude
originale avait
c'était conduite on aurait pu identifier
les meilleures mesures sur les ponts
actuels je pense que les dernières les
informations commencent à sortir on a
demandé au bureau de projet d'étudier
des voies réversibles on a demandé au
bureau de projet d'étudier juste le
transport collectif dans le troisième
lien on a demandé au bureau de projet
d'analyser différents scénarios fait que
je pense qu'on est revenu en arrière
pour finalement faire l'étude
d'opportunité qui était plus complète
puis peut-être moi j'ai grand espoir que
tu sais c'est oui il y a du bruit autour
du troisième lien uniquement en
transport collectif
ok je crois pas
mais malgré tout je pense que les bonnes
décisions vont se prendre vont se
prendre parce que là la Société des
traversiers du Québec va probablement
racheter des traversiers avec où on peut
circuler en voix en automobile parce que
c'est quand même un lien il y a quand
même traversé
peut-être qu'on peut ajouter des
navettes fluviales entre les deux rives
pour les cyclistes puis prendre
davantage les piétons mais aussi avoir
une option pour les pour les véhicules
ça c'était dans ce qui était dans les
plans c'est qu'il y en ait pu le
traversier avec les véhicules entre les
deux rives là on revient sur la décision
là on analyse les voix
les voir la voie reversible sur le pont
on dit c'est peut-être pas une bonne
idée peut-être que la meilleure idée
c'est vraiment l'accès aux ponts donc
revoir les spaghettis des ponts pour
améliorer la fluidité parce que c'est
une question d'accès au pont parce
qu'une fois rentre sur le pont il y a
pas vraiment de problème c'est que je
pense que malgré tout le bruit je pense
qu'on va en arriver à des bons à des
bons choix parce que les études se font
fait quand même semi optimiste
parce que le tramway continue pendant ce
temps-là le projet du tramway c'est un
projet en lequel tu as pas froid non
plus non parce que dans le fond
historiquement là le projet de tramway
je pense qu'il y aurait dû se réaliser
lorsque les premières études de
faisabilité du RTC en 2002 2003 puis à
l'époque ça coûtait beaucoup moins cher
mais à l'époque le gouvernement avait
pas voulu le financer parce qu'il disait
qu'il y avait des enjeux d'acceptabilité
sociale parce que c'est normal
normalement quand tu fais un projet de
tramway puis quand tu regardes les
projets de tramways dans le monde qui
fonctionne c'est que tu enlèves la
capacité routière
donc à l'époque on avait jugé que
c'était pas là on le voit c'est là en ce
moment il y a même pas de réduction de
la capacité routière ou très peu avec le
tramway
les gens il y a très peu d'acceptabilité
sociale même si on a gardé sinon
augmenter la capacité routière à Québec
puis à l'époque on le savait plus que le
tramway est incompatible avec les armes
sur un élève les trois boisés qui vont
être coupés l'impact environnemental des
tramways la dalle de béton donc on
savait pas ça on le suit le pendant les
études l'étude du bac
le bureau d'audience publique sont
environnement c'est là où toutes les
informations là comme
les gens ont pas voter ou choisir en
toute connaissance de cause même les
prix c'est ça c'est
[Musique]
un scientifique s'appelle benflyberg qui
publie sur les grandes les mégas c'est
comme un le syndrome des mégas il y en a
de moins en moins qui rencontre leurs
objectifs puis il y en a plus de plus en
plus qui sont construits les politiques
continuent à aller de l'avant avec les
mégas projets sauf que pour qu'un projet
passe
on minimise les risques puis on maximise
les objectifs ou les bénéfices sont
associés à ces projets là c'est ça qu'on
voit avec le projet de tramway les coûts
minimisés les bénéfices maximisés parce
qu'il y a eu des contre-études dans le
chalandage qui démontrent que
la chalandage était pas il y a des
stations là c'était 40% sur surestimer
la gendar du tramway puis on voit avec
la pandémie ça comprend même pas les
chiffres de la pandémie fait que c'est
sûr que moi au début là j'étais une
j'étais pour le tramway là parce que
pour le tramway sur un éléphant parce
que tu veux augmenter la capacité là où
il y a le plus d'achalandage
puis j'étais pour le projet qui avait
été mis de l'avant par le RTC en 2002
2003 c'est-à-dire jusqu'à Marly
essentiellement les axes existants puis
à l'époque c'était vraiment moins cher
de faire des projets mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'aujourd'hui étant donné ce
qu'on sait sur les coûts sur les autres
possibilités qui ont pas été étudiées
sur la dynamique de la circulation pour
le développement immobilier à Québec je
pense que c'est pas le bon projet
puisqu'il devrait pas être réalisé tout
simplement je pense qu'on serait mieux
sans
le risque regardez Ottawa là
avec les problèmes qu'ils ont ça a toute
des structuré les transports collectifs
il y a un risque et ça flotte solide
puis là on est dans une ville où c'est
là où le tramway passe là
les surtout au centre-ville de Québec
les ports modales des transports
collectifs et actifs c'est genre 50% des
jeux les paramètres sont super bonnes
puis à Québec le problème c'est le
Bourneuf le Bourgneuf centre-ville il
n'y a pas encore de lien direct en
transport collectif
puis aussi de du Nord au nord
tout le nord qui se développe
puis c'est ces gens-là que tu veux qui
embarquent dans le transport collectif
mais eux ils n'ont pas d'offre
puis ils sont contre le tramway en plus
il va falloir qu'il débarque à la Croix
Rouge
il pourra pas venir directement au
centre-ville ils vont faire un transfert
je le vois pas comment que ça peut bien
aller je souhaite
que ça se produise pas si ça se produise
je l'ai excusez-moi je leur ai dit et
que puis-je faire moi je suis juste
quelle scientifique le je suis pas une
politique
puis mais il y a quand même un problème
à Québec de thé les gens tu le dis
tantôt je pense que c'est 10% des gens
qui font qui prennent des transports
quand même pour les travailler
il y a une culture du char à Québec qui
est vraiment forte vraiment plus que la
camorréal
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec ça c'est quoi la bonne solution tu
as parlé il y a d'autres d'autres
alternatives qui ont pas été
étudié ça serait quoi selon toi
comment qu'on pourrait améliorer la
situation
de 1
c'est je pense qu'on est dû pour un bon
exercice de consultation et de
participation c'est qu'il y a une agence
notoriété neutre qui fasse un bilan puis
avec parce que dans le fond
on va faire une longue question
d'enfant l'intérêt collectif sur un
territoire là c'est négocier qui parce
que plusieurs parties qui ont droit
d'avoir voie au chapitre les promoteurs
immobiliers ont droit d'avoir droit au
chapitre les gens qui font du vélo qui
veulent marcher ils ont le droit d'avoir
vos chapitre puis les automobilistes ils
ont droit d'avoir vos chapitre puis il
faut prendre aussi soin des gens qui ont
pas de voix donc
l'intérêt collectif il négocié c'est
qu'il faut que tout ce beau monde là
qui est un forum pour que les gens se
parlent qui a un recadrage un peu des
discours et des intérêts pour qu'on en
vienne à une solution qui négociée par
tout le monde ce qui implique que
personne arrive avec sa solution dès le
départ puis qu'on fasse des études où on
étudie l'ensemble des options que ça
soit pas biaisé puis qu'il y a de
l'information transparente comme ça
parce que à la fin c'est sûr que c'est
les politiques choisissent ou par où on
fait après ça approuvé par référendum
mais que les autres options qui auront
pas été retenues ben on sait pourquoi
les gens ils savent pourquoi il y a un
débat puis c'est ça c'est ça c'est comme
les gens qui sont contre le tramway à ce
moment qui veulent un référendum si ça
passe on va se taire
ça va être la majorité qui va l'avoir tu
sais à un moment donné comme j'ai il
faut pas prendre les gens pour des pour
des nonos là donc
dans un bon exercice de participation et
de planification qui réalisait par une
agence neutre qui a des objectifs
objectifs de réduction déjà subjectif de
transfertment dans l'objectif d'un c'est
sûr que à court terme c'est pour
atteindre les objectifs du GIEC qui est
atteindre le pic des émissions d'ici
2025 qui demain matin
c'est pas en construisant des grandes
infrastructures lourdes
qu'on va atteindre ses objectifs là
donc il faut que ça passe
essentiellement par des modes qui sont
plus sobre en carbone puis qui sont de
manière
corrélaire qui sont plus sobre aussi
financièrement donc
de temps à mettre en place aussi donc
optimiser les structures qui sont déjà
là finalement plutôt que dans construire
des nouvelles
il y a pas de lien direct entre le
Bourgneuf puis le centre ville de Québec
encore c'est le deuxième axe de
déplacement commencez donc par ça passer
par la pente douce Marie de
l'Incarnation chukchouc puis les gens
c'est les autres je pense que les
opposants ont tramway qui sont dans les
couronnes Nord si on ne fait pas le
tramway puis qu'on implante des voies
réservées pour le transport collectif
les autobus et tout ça je pense qu'ils
vont le ils vont l'accepter
ouais je pense aussi la question de la
tarification programme de réduction du
navetage pour les employeurs que les
employeurs paient pour que leur les
employés aient accès gratuit que ça
finance l'exploitation ça je pense que
c'est une ce serait une très bien très
bonne idée aussi parce que là les gens
ils auraient le service puis ils
auraient aussi de l'accès au service
gratuit mais ce serait payé par l'emploi
leur employeur c'est que ça passe par
l'amélioration de l'offre de service
puis aussi des programmes incitatifs
mais les gens sont plus sensibles à la
qualité du service qu'au prix par
exemple si un investissement à faire
c'est d'abord dans la qualité du service
donc
juste de mon expérience personnelle
mettons 4 et 50 ou 5 et 50 pour le
billet de bus si si à 5 et 50
l'expérience est rapide et facile ça va
même pas je vois même pas y penser
donc pour toi l'autobus
c'est encore une bonne solution dans le
sens que si on l'améliore si on
l'optimise c'est par là que ça passe
c'est quoi l'avantage d'un tramway en
fait verser un autobus pourquoi qu'on
parce que le tramway son trajet réservé
finalement il y a
il y a la voix fidélisée
du trafic
essentiellement mettez du papier
12 ans construire ça a été vraiment long
ça c'est un problème politique là c'est
pas un problème de mode en tant que tel
mais
écoute je me demande c'est sûr que en
termes de confort c'était moins
comme ça tout le temps
mais du point de vue de la fiabilité
je pense qu'on peut atteindre des
niveaux équivalents avec un beauty une
voix dédiée au transport collectif ou
bus tu peux atteindre des niveaux parce
que essentiellement ce que le bureau de
projet du
tramway dit c'est que il va y avoir des
avantages à cause d'une plus grande
fréquence
ok mais tu veux plus fréquent ou
une grande fiabilité mais dans ce cas-là
mettez des feux de préemption puis
puis le tramway va le bus va aller voir
atteindre des niveaux qui sont
comparables puis
si un arrêt de service si il y a une
porte qui ferme pas là c'est toutes les
autres qui vont qui vont stopper c'est
qu'au niveau de la fiabilité moi je le
sais pas là si il y a un plus grand
risque ça c'est sûr avec le projet de
tramway j'imagine qu'il y ait aussi la
question de l'électrification des
autobus il faut que tu es électrifie ta
flotte d'autobus pour ça ça va se faire
ça ça va se faire parce que le
gouvernement du Québec ne finance plus
le but hybride finance juste débute
électrique
piment ça va être une bonne option aussi
là quand il y a des quand euh
la capacité et tout ça ça peut c'est pas
nécessairement de mauvaise chose et puis
c'est bride pour la résilience du
système puis là on parle de bus on parle
de tramway on parle de transport
collectif mais il y a aussi les
transports actifs à Québec essaie de
déplacer en vélo toi c'est
que
vous
à travers l’hôpital Laval effectivement
à la bête à Montréal l'habitude pierre à
court jusqu'à son travail tout le temps
puis là elle faisait aussi à Québec mais
Sainte-Foy tout au long
chemin cinq fois à cause de moi
tout le long là
mon calme tu sais mais sinon c'est genre
il y a des grosses constructions
mais ouais c'est pas fait pour cela
l'attitude mettant des automobilistes
envers les piétons les cyclistes à
Québec
à Montréal c'est comme allez-y mais moi
je vais y aller en dernier avec mon auto
puis à Québec c'est
oh puis c'est moi qui parle c'est puis
il voulait pas si longtemps il y avait
encore des auteurs des radios qui disait
genre
mais je pense qu'il faut un
rééquilibrage et la guerre à l'auto
c'est la guerre à tous mais c'est parce
que là c'est du tout à l'auto là les
gens ont pas le jeté ils prennent la
liberté mais parce que les gens ont pas
le choix de prendre la voiture
si on veut marcher si on veut prendre le
vélo on peut pas c'est que c'est pas une
guerre à l'auto c'est
la liberté de choix pour tout le monde
on est quand même Québec centré dans les
projets qu'on a qu'on a abordé
maintenant mais pour les gens toi
mettons tu regardes Montréal étant une
métropole
internationale
comment est-ce que tu mets ton sur un
échelle de 0 à 6 atomes
mais genre pour un échelle de 0 à 10
mettons la
mobilité à Montréal puis
le design
urbain mais la planification urbaine tu
la mets à combien sur un échelle de 0 à
10 parce que ça attaque à Québec c'est
assez médiocre si tu veux pas avoir de
voiture à moins que tu habites dans deux
quartiers là mais à Montréal sur ça
dans les palmarès chaque fois qu'il y a
des évaluations des études comparées on
est toujours dans le top ah ouais
toujours dans le top
c'est ça à cause de la grâce au métro
grâce au métro
aussi aux nouveaux investissements c'est
le rêve le réseau le réseau express vélo
là il y a le REM on va voir si ça se
passe bien ça coûte très cher au
gouvernement
après
vous êtes chanceux que j'habite à Québec
j'habite à Montréal
sur toutes les radios
une fois par semaine
on y reviendra je préfère je veux juste
pas embarquer là-dedans
le tramway si j'habitais pas à Québec là
j'aurais jamais la confiance que j'ai
envers ce projet parce que je le connais
je connais la je connais
le projet comme le fond de ma poche le
milieu urbain et tout ça je viens pas de
Montréal il y a plein d'experts à
Montréal j'ai laissé se prononcer sur
leur projet je veux pas m'aider de ce
qui me regarde pas tant
un petit peu quand même mais au niveau
de la gouvernance au niveau de la
gouvernance
ça coûte très cher
ça coûte très cher puis je pense que la
leçon de
des mandats qui ont été donnés à ces des
PQ infra la création de des pékins infra
pour construire le REM
c'est parce que les pouvoirs publics ont
beaucoup de difficultés à réaliser des
sociétés de transport les STM
le RTC à Québec beaucoup de difficultés
à réaliser des mégas de transport fait
que je pense qu'il faut la leçon de ça
c'est qu'il faut renforcer la capacité
des pouvoirs publics à réaliser des
grands projets d'infrastructure au lieu
de donner au privé parce que ça ne coûte
vraiment plus cher donc ça c'était fait
que je dirais juste mais le fait mettons
que tu dis que Montréal se classe
vraiment bien à l'international grâce au
métro c'est pas aussi
un peu une une des raisons pourquoi
faudrait
investir dans des grands projets
d'infrastructure c'est plus là on peut
parler du ben si on parlait évidemment
du tramway le tramway qui est un grand
projet d'infrastructure qui va être
massif à faire qui va coûter extrêmement
cher qui va être mais qui est
éventuellement va être mis en place pour
des années
c'est parce que moi maintenant je me
replace en fait si aujourd'hui il y
avait pas de métro à Montréal puis que
là quelqu'un arrivait avec un faut faire
un métro il va cinq lignes ça va être ça
ça va être des projets qui vont durer 20
ans on va creuser en dessous de la ville
ça va coûter des milliards et des
milliards et des milliards peut-être
quelqu'un mettrait le pied sur le frein
en vrai on a des autobus
comment est-ce qu'on réconcilie ces deux
idées là parce que j'imagine que quand
ils ont construit le métro il y avait
des études qui disaient que c'était bon
et puis
ils sont peut-être allés à l'aveugle en
fait c'est encore ça a pu encore plus
mon point si c'est ça le cas de dire et
là peut-être que puis aujourd'hui on est
content on collectivement est vraiment
content d'avoir un métro parce que ça
comme tu dis si Montréal sort haut dans
les palmarès des villes grâce à ça
comment est-ce qu'on réconcilite ces
deux idées là quand on se dit ouais on a
déjà un système de bus à Québec on a
déjà un pont à Montréal à la place du
renne mais en même temps
c'est des grands projets qui sont comme
qui semble être un investissement sur le
non seulement le long terme et le
support long terme mais en ce moment
c'est sûr que le tramway est sur
capacitaire parce que le pic à Québec
c'est les heures de pointe plant les
heures de pointe on les on a réussi à
les aplatir
c'est quand tu regardes la politique de
mobilité durable du gouvernement c'est
RTA c'est réduire transféré puis
améliorer réduire la demande on est
encore là on devrait encore comme
continuer à travailler là-dedans qui est
plus sobre
transfert modal c'est améliorer les
services de transport collectif pour
avoir un certain transfert je pense pas
que le tramway quand tu regardes le
transfert Moder du tramway les chips
sont juste pas là
et sur ces trois pas un transfert modal
à l'extérieur des des la zone de
captation dans les banlieues ils disent
c'est 1% mais c'est des chiffres de ce
langage qui sont surestimés on va
dépenser 6 7 milliards pour pas modifier
les parts modernes les transports
collectifs à Québec puis améliorer ça
c'est l'électrification je pense que
l'électrification
je pense qu'on peut d'abord faire les
mesures de réduction de la demande qui
transforme dans l'avant de
l'électrification ça se fait ça se fait
parce qu'on finance plus les autobus
puis les autobus hybrides ou au diesel
puis on électrifie la flotte des la
flotte automobile puis même le c'est pas
c'est le coût bénéfice de ces mesures là
la tonne de CO2 éviter c'est pas la
meilleure investissement
fait que si tu prends en compte les
critères là tu sais le transfert modal
réduction des GES
il sera pas carbonate avant 2041 selon
leur chiffre qui sont surestimés
je pense qu'on peut faire autre chose je
pense qu'on peut faire autre chose
concrètement c'est pour ça je dis c'est
beau le transport collectif là puis j'en
reviens pas que je suis contre un projet
de transport collectif on atteint les
Nouvelles Frontières tu comprends tu
sais qu'ils sont preneurs en fait
c'est comme je rédigeais mon premier
rapport dans le fond quand j'ai témoigné
au bas j'ai témoigné j'ai recommandé
qu'on que le projet reste en
planification ça passe par référendum
puis j'avais donné quelques
recommandations et quand j'ai pris un
deux semaines en juillet au chalet mes
vacances j'aurais déjà un rapport
j'étais le genre viens pas qu'on en est
rendu là que finalement c'est peut-être
pas une si bonne idée que ça les méga
projet
mais si tu si tu sautes si ce projet-là
dans sa forme actuelle comment qu'il est
dessiné puis comment qui
comme un qui est pensé ou c'est ou peu
importe comment qui serait peu importe à
trajet qui aurait peu importe ça c'est
pas une bonne idée
si ça pourrait être mener être à moins
dans une autre forme mais non parce que
c'est incompatible avec le cadre naturel
de Québec parce que tu es obligé de
couper les arbres sur un élevac pour moi
ça fait un non sens complètement un nom
sens dans un contexte d'urgence
climatique puis de qu'il faut réduire
nos émissions de JS à cause qui doit
couper les arbres tu dois tu peux pas
avoir le siemenses la solution qui avait
proposé d'enfouir les fils ils ont même
pas soumis parce que cette parce que
c'est pas fiable leur technologie
ne passe pas les hivers le sait pas
encore testé puis il voulait avoir la
solution la plus fiable possible
puis la question du TC c'est sûr qu'il y
a des gens qui mettent un qui met de
l'avant la solution du du métro Val donc
un métro léger que tu peux augmenter ta
capacité au fur et à mesure
ce qui reste ça reste que c'est très
cher
puis
pour les souterrains mettez il y a pas
eu d'études d'opportunités qui a été
faite parce que l'étude d'opportunité a
le com était biaisé en faveur du tramway
puis le fait qu'on l'est pas étudié à sa
juste valeur
ça fait en sorte que ça sème des doutes
moi je suis pas prête à la rejeter
d'emblée cette option là aussi je
l'achète d'emblée oui parce que
l'objectif c'est de réduire les
émissions le plus vite possible puis on
est on le voit déjà que le tramway est
sur capacteur tu veux mettre un métro tu
dis toi-même que les bus sont vides tu
veux mettre un métro
aussi non c'est quoi en fait comment
qu'on fait comment qu'on
comment qu'on fait les gens prendre le
bus parce qu'elles sont vides ils sont
là mais ils sont vides
la fin de semaine quand les gens ils
viennent au festival l'été puis les gens
ils viennent faire leur petit ours sur
quartier il y en a pas de congestion le
rocher il d'abord
il est pas sur un univers il est sur
Grande Allée davantage de trafic sur le
grand public notre cher directeur de la
mobilité durable à Québec comme il
réseau artérielle métropolitain contrôle
les feux de circulation ça roule ça
roule ça roule ça roule ça roule c'est
fluide fluide fluide il est pas là le
problème là
des gens qui sont pour le tramway c'est
la congestion des bus à l'heure de
pointe Coline parlementaire
les bus sont congés des trains il y a le
phénomène des trains bus
c'est ça le problème on s'attaque à ce
problème là
il y a eu un coupeur de une coupure de
service dans les Express qui vont voir
dans le bois qui vont avoir beau port et
tout ça ils ont coupé les pieds il y a
du monde dans les Express là qui marche
pour dans le fond il y a pas encore
assez de trafic à Québec pour que le
monde aille envie de prendre le bus
finalement
je sais pas si ça doit être un livre
puis les gens sont prêts à voyager 30
minutes le matin 30 minutes le soir pour
se rendre au à leur domicile le matin
donc tant que tu fais ton 30 minutes en
auto tu es bon là d'avoir de
Transformers puis 30 minutes à Québec tu
te rends n'importe où tu seras n'importe
où peu importe
[Musique]
dans ce sens-là en tout cas
là on parle
on a comme là on parle des villes on a
commencé j'étais posé la question sur le
train
moi au Québec je trouve que c'est
timeton moi j'aurais pas de chance
j'habite comme je disais dans saint
Jean-Baptiste j'aurais pas de chance ça
me ferait plaisir de pas avoir de short
pour ma vie tous les jours j'en ai même
pas besoin j'ai été il a 807 à côté de
chez nous c'est vraiment rapide je suis
capable de me rendre partout à Québec
sans genre
comment on fait pour
les gens comme moi mettons qui
voudraient se délaisser de leur voiture
ou pas l'utiliser
mais qui veulent par exemple aller en
région au Québec les se promener passer
de Québec Montréal aller dans le bas du
fleuve allez au lac Saint-Jean c'est ça
se fait pas c'est quasiment c'est si je
veux aller au Lac St-Jean mettons au
chalet de ma mère là faut que j'aille
faut que je prenne l'autobus jusqu'à
Alma plus pour quelqu'un vienne nous
chercher puis là je fais 30 minutes de
charge
me rendre comment on fait c'est quoi un
réseau de transport qui est efficace
au Québec en entier selon toi
on a vu beaucoup beaucoup de
propositions pendant la campagne
électorale
des réseaux de train qui faisaient
toutes les Québec je pense que Québec
raï que ça c'était la proposition de
Québec solidaire qui apparaissait comme
une super solution mais encore une fois
un énorme projet puis est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment tant de monde que ceux qui
prendraient le train jusqu'à Gasper là
en Gaspésie l'hiver à partir de Montréal
c'est de faire un chemin de voie ferrée
jusqu'à là-bas pour deux personnes c'est
quand même stock là
surtout que même par exemple certaines
villes en périphérie de Montréal ont de
la difficulté à se rendre par exemple au
métro de Longueuil ou au réseau offert
par la RTM juste les ou au service d'exo
par exemple c'est Montréal c'est très
dense il y a une bonne de population
mais je pense que les options ce qu'on
voit au Québec par exemple le Flexibus
la transport à la demande comme quand tu
fais des réservations pour qu'il y a
pour qu'un mini bus ou vienne te
chercher puis votre portée
à ton point de destination à un arrêt
d'autobus ça c'est hyper populaire fait
que ça des options de transport à la
demande dans les endroits qui sont plus
de banlieue ça peut être une bonne une
bonne option il y a plusieurs villes en
région qui commence à implanter des
niveaux des réseaux de navette de
transport collectif dans Charlevoix il y
a deux trois lignes qui ont été qui ont
été implantés depuis l'automne très
convenient
des petits des petits minibus
locaux là c'est les MRC qui peuvent
mettre ça en place
des régies intermunicipales il y en a
une Gaspésie de la Madeleine donc ça je
pense que il y a de plus en plus de
transports en région mais le transport
intérieurement
ce non pardonnance dès que tu sors du
corps d'or Québec Montréal le ouf
ça c'est le privé c'est le privé petit
dans le fond
très difficile de trouver des seuils de
rentabilité qu'on réduit au maximum
c'est un accord qui faisait le service
là toute la côte nord et tout ça ils ont
vraiment réduit la robe de service c'est
fou donc quand il faut que le
gouvernement intervienne il faut
subventionner se transport là parce que
les transporteurs privés donnent pas le
service donc je pense que ça devrait
être une priorité
c'est aussi l'accessibilité parce que
moi mettons
je viens ici à peu près deux fois par
mois
si je prenais juste le transport en
commun
deux fois par mois Québec Montréal c'est
mon paiement
en deux allers-retours ça fait pas de
sens
c'est complètement débile de penser que
le monde vont changer leur habitude
quand c'est seul la réalité c'est ça
coûte quasiment 180 pièces aller-retour
Québec Montréal
mais ça c'est un problème le fait que
l'accès au crédit pour l'achat de
voiture soit si facile ça c'est ce qui
contribue à au nombre de véhicules par
ménage et tout ça là c'est là que l'éco
fiscalité entre dans le portrait
augmenter le coût d'avoir une voiture là
pour envoyer un signal de prix diminuer
l'avantage comparatif de l'automobile
comparativement au mode de transport
collectif
descendre le prix parce que on dirait
avoir un chat ça coûte cher là je
comprends ce que tu veux dire de
il y a une taxe c'est comme 20 000
pièces par année pour juste pouvoir
acheter un short fait que 20 000 pièces
pour après ça payer ton char avec le
monde le monde sont dans le souterrain
il y a personne tu vois il y a deux
voitures c'est des Lamborghini mettons
que tu vas se promener dans le
centre-ville de Singapour sinon tout le
monde c'est comme des fourmis dans le
réseau souterrain mais
ça me semble que de monter le prix d'un
char c'est que dans le fond j'imagine
que j'en aurai pas
ça
que ça ferait effectivement comme ils
vont faire dans la grande région de
Montréal et les droits d'immatriculation
les villes de la CMM vont percevoir un
59 dollars à partir de 2024 de plus que
les droits d'immatriculation de la sac
puis ça ça va servir à financer les
transports collectifs
tu fais les deux en même temps ta ligne
les instituts les mesures du basilic
la voiture électrique c'est de plus en
plus
accessible et efficace et avec une
autonomie de plus en plus intéressante
puis ça probablement continuer dans
cette direction-là selon toi
en termes de réduction des GS c'est une
solution intéressante la voiture
électrique ou c'est un Play Store sur un
bobo
je pense que c'est un blaster sur un
puis quand on regarde la croissance de
la demande en minéraux en terre rare
puis en minéraux critique et stratégique
puis sécuriser les chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour les batteries
[Musique]
on est encore dans une dynamique
extractiviste
les clés miniers
les stratégies parce que là c'est la
nouvelle
géopolitique mondiale qui est comme une
reconfiguration puis il y a les
relations internationales du Canada qui
s'ajuste en fonction de ses besoins là
en approvisionnement en matériaux
critique et stratégique pour avoir une
plus grande indépendance
pour sécuriser les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
oui
environnemental non
idéalement non faudrait laisser les
ressources dans le sol faudrait réduire
au maximum notre demande d'énergie
fossile et de ressources non
renouvelables mais là si on embarque
dans les considérations géopolitiques
de sécurité nationale mais peut-être
qu'il faut à quelques endroits en
prélever des ressources naturelles ou
comment combien qui redistribution la
richesse autochtone parlons-en mais là
personne n'en parle
c'est pas transparent il y a pas de
vision il y a une vision mais c'est pas
connu des gens puis les gens qui en
subissent ces gens on va acheter des
clés mini pour pas que ça soit développé
c'est vraiment au niveau micro local
mais c'est pas il y a pas d'organisation
nécessairement au niveau national qu'une
mise en commun des ressources d'une
mobilisation et tout ça mais
s'il y a vraiment une transformation là
de notre économie puis on va on essaie
de réduire l'exploitation de l'énergie
fossile
et tout ça projette Terre-Neuve
d'extraction pétrolière ça serait
peut-être le dernier mais de l'autre
bord oh finalement on va creuser partout
on remplace un combustible par un autre
type de d'énergie
à court terme est-ce qu'on va atteindre
nos
objectifs de réduction non
en même temps on le regarde on le
regarde quand même avec
la technologie qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
alors qu'on sait quand même à quelle
vitesse ça évolue
c'est l'homme étant c'est je pense que
de continuer à explorer cet avenue là
c'est la meilleure affaire qu'on peut
faire parce que mais pas la meilleure
affaire qu'on peut faire on peut faire
on peut faire un million d'affaires mais
on n'a pas vraiment le choix parce que
demain matin et puis on le dit tantôt
2025 c'est demain la veille mais on n'a
pas le choix de faire ça c'est que
j'imagine qu'à la vitesse à laquelle la
technologie de voiture électrique avance
puis la technologie d'une nouvelle
batterie puis des choses qui vont être
capables d'être plus vert j'imagine
parce que là on est si on prend
l'échelle des des voitures la
technologie électrique à deux ans
c'est une voix vraiment exploitée
exploiter pour sans exploitation mais
c'est une voix à explorer bien sûr
vivement là parce que si on réussit à
trouver puis je veux dire des gens
beaucoup plus intelligents que moi qui
travaillent là-dessus un moment où
est-ce qu'on se passe
mais encore une fois c'est parce que je
pense que
c'est le genre de projet qu'il faut voir
essayez de voir au plus long terme même
si comme un tiens on parlait de
l'intelligence artificielle
on a même été on sait pas encore c'est
quoi on sait pas c'est quoi c'est pas ça
j'imagine que c'est une option mais
encore une fois toute peut être faite
simultanément
trop tard
[Musique]
mais c'est sûr
pas le choix c'est sûr mais comment
ouais
puis effectivement puis même c'est la
même chose pour le troisième lien qu'on
parle de tantôt un manque complet de
transparence des gens qui prennent des
décisions qui ont la vision sur le long
terme tu sais on apprenait que les trois
amis il y avait commencé les études sur
un lien très exclusivement transport
collectif
personne n'a parlé de ça on ne savait
aucune idée question transparence ça
revient à ce que tu disais de pas
prendre le monde pour des caves mais
prendre le monde pour des caves ça donne
des sièges
quand même le modèle de on est chacun
dans notre chambre
je fais la route aussi Québec qui est
Montréal souvent ou juste tu promènes en
char en général puis quand tu regardes
dans les autres souvent c'est une
personne dans l'auto il y a cinq places
dans un auto mais c'est souvent une
personne dans un auto ou deux mais il y
a comme une perte de
comment qu'on décide de se déplacer
quand que souvent justement tu fais
Québec Montréal on est tous dans nos
chars
qui
est un ensemble comme Catherine Morency
dit le qui est professeur à
Polytechnique qui a la chair mobilité
elle dit on transporte du vide les gens
sont dans leur voiture là c'est du c'est
de l'air le et du métal donc qui est fou
transporter des individus et non pas des
véhicules c'est pour ça qu'il faut
penser en termes de mutualisation
de la covoiturage le transport collectif
ça m'apparaît comme une avenue hyper
intéressante mettons mais on dirait que
c'est encore ultra marginal je sais pas
si ça lit dans les dans les faits dans
les chiffres le médecin mettons
d'initiatives comme Amigo Express de mes
affaires qui sont quand même somme toute
c'est pas
si c'est pas
l'impression que des mesures qui
gouvernementales qui vient encourager ça
effectivement
d'imaginez Apple mettez
non mais pas Hubert mais juste au début
uber au début c'était présenté comme
étant un arbre de covoiturage
pour gagner deux autres personnes ça
nous avait pris une heure retourner
jusqu'à l'aéroport c'était cool
non mais c'est juste si maintenant il y
avait une manière ultra efficace de dire
ben moi je mettais moi je suis musicien
dans la vie j'ai pas le choix genre je
me déplace tout le temps avec faut de
l'instrument ça me prend en charge
mon chemin bing bang je les ramasse
c'est simple efficace mettant plus
efficace que mettons un truc express
pour trouver des solutions
comme une auto
comme une auto mais comme une auto
fournissent pas l'été les mêmes les
Enterprise de ce monde fournissent pas
je sais pas à quel point Amigo Express
c'est pas c'est toujours aussi populaire
que c'est l'été dans le temps mais c'est
vraiment moins cher là mais oui qu'être
prendre le bus donc il faut vraiment ce
qui appelle le transport c'est
multiplier les options là multiplie les
options pour que les gens aient pas
c'est quand on a besoin de prendre une
voiture ben on peut en louer une pour un
certain moment tu sais qu'il y a des
flottes de véhicules mutualisés
puis lorsqu'on fait des déplacements ben
réduire la distance la fréquence c'est
l'aménagement du territoire la même
chose aussi si justement des automobiles
communes la plupart du temps
les gens qui ont des autos les plupart
du temps c'est tout ne roulent pas la
majorité du temps le taux ne sert pas si
un peu servir le reste du temps aussi ça
mais c'est ça après ça faut que tu
sais Airbnb des voitures
puis maintenant qu'on va
dans une autre direction puis comprend
mettons un film de science-fiction comme
rapport minoritaire où est-ce que ils
ont comme un système de
embarque dans une affaire qui conduit
tout seul puis on n'est pas loin de ça
si on pense aux voitures électriques
puis mettons l'intelligence artificielle
qui serait capable de planifier les
déplacements de tout le monde pour
éviter
qu'aide des bouchons de circulation dans
le fond que les voitures se conduiraient
parallèlement pour t'amener du point A
au point B puis genre en taille main
toutes les voitures avec toutes les
autres voitures qui sont genre sur une
grille
je suis vraiment pas taken enthousiaste
mais tu penses pas que les solutions
vont passer par par là par
l'intelligence artificielle par
des nouvelles technologies qui peuvent
optimiser ce genre de déplacement mais
on peut je dis pas qu'il faut pas
nécessairement aller de l'avant avec ses
études là ou explorer ses avenues là
c'est juste que moi je suis pas dans
tout ça m'intéresse pas
dans la manière dont les villes peuvent
se transformer peuvent
inciter les gens à prendre les
transports collectifs
davantage de revenus pour ne pas avoir
tout le jour à se développer donc les
recherches en ce moment ça porte sur ça
ça part sur l'éco-fiscalité municipale
les redevances de développement donc
c'est ces questions là puis donc c'est
pas c'est pas dans mon corps
toi l'idée de densification des villes
j'imagine que c'est une idée que tu
championnes champion ne mais
j'ai de la musique on en a parlé souvent
sur podcast mais je la misère à
réconcilier l'idée
je deviens anxieux à penser à ça on
dirait ça me rend anxieux de penser à
genre quel type de densification aussi
parce que ça prend quand même un accès
ça prend un accès au parc et oui la
densité
ou grand parc
il faut avoir accès aux fleuves il faut
avoir accès plein d'abramme il faut que
tout le monde ait accès à quand même des
espaces où être en nature donc oui la
densification mais pas n'importe comment
j'allais courir sur Mont-Royal samedi
puis je voulais mourir il y avait du
monde à l'infini il y avait un beau parc
au sommet de Montréal un beau parc un
lac il y avait du monde
a comme une comme quand tu vois des
photos sur une plage le genre au spring
break à Miami du monde
ça entre les tapis de pique-nique de
famille qui se connaissent pas tantôt ça
pour moi c'est pas une vision saine
tout le monde a un chalet tout le monde
tout le monde a un chalet que tu dois
prendre ton char puis pour aller puis
l'hiver un VUS je pense pas que c'est
une bonne solution non plus
je pense pas non comment est-ce qu'on
l'a la main ensemble
parce que je suis pas proche de la
nature
mais en fait c'est que si tu
t'identifies davantage de plus d'espace
de conservation des espaces naturels
plus tu fais des grands participants les
gens là qui ont qui louent l'été des
chalets à la cpacle c'est vraiment
extraordinaire là ce sont des beaux
endroits c'est public c'est pas trop
cher
donc ça serait ça ma réponse si tu
densifies tu as moins besoin d'espace
pour l'unif familial et tout ça tu peux
te permettre de conserver des espaces
naturels d'avoir un accès public à ces
espaces naturels
parce que j'ai l'impression que ça
ferait que bonne chance pour essayer de
trouver un chalet à ses pacle le weekend
non mais c'est déjà faut déjà que tu
réserves mettons juste maintenant faut
déjà que tu réserves trois semaines de
trois mois d'avance pour avoir ton
chalet à ses Pâques
trois mois d'avance c'est pas super
maintenant tu veux partir en week-end
mettons moi c'est ça que je veux faire
je vais sortir un week-end quelque part
si tu réserves je comprends mais ton
réservé pour un chalet pour avoir
mettons tes vacances donc une job
standard qui est pas faire des podcasts
deux semaines de vacances que tu sais
d'avance tu sais que ça va être calme
l'année prochaine des deux semaines de
vacances je peux planifier tes ton
triple dans le même ces deux semaines là
ça je comprends ça tu peux louer ton
chalet de la Sepac dans ce temps-là mais
si tu as un long weekend
qui arrive que toi tu veux sortir de la
ville puis là tu es dans un
tu es dans une ville qui est densifiée
qui est optimisée pour
les petites villes comme on parlait
tantôt ou laisser je pense je m'en vais
c'est quoi le terme que tu utilisais
pour l'hiver à 15 minutes
là-dedans puis tu habites là-dedans avec
vraiment beaucoup de monde qui sont
super optimisés pour se promener puis
faire leur vie puis aller au Mont Royal
le samedi mettons
New York c'est de vivre dans cette
densité aussi élever le
pas pour tout le monde je pense
ben non mais c'est parce que les gens
ils ont le privilège avant le choix ici
dans les îles comme ça à Taïwan
mais ils ont ils dansent mais ils
concernent leur milieu naturel il y a
des grands parcs c'est pas Hong Kong
même encore il y a des grands parcs
aussi
puis je pense que ici on a le luxe et le
privilège à pouvoir se dire oh il faut
que je réserve mon chalet 3 mois à
l'avance
on est bien on est genre c'est le
paradis sur terre le Québec là
on s'entend là
c'est vrai c'est de dire oui au Québec
c'est la meilleure place pour vivre ou
il fait que chaque fois qu'on a des
débats publics sur les trucs on
des mouches essentiellement
qui se passe ou pas essentiellement
à l'échelle planète Terre à l'échelle
mondiale c'est c'est pas grand chose là
tu sais pour nous c'est énorme pour en
parler ouais exact c'est ça sauf que
toutes ces toutes ces débats qu'on a
nous on reste vraiment bien au Québec
loin de là
kumbayor on est tellement bien ici
faites ce que vous voulez non non c'est
juste de remettre en perspective et tout
ça
mettons peu importe où je pense tu fais
de la politique ou bien tu participes au
début
publics
toi d'ailleurs par rapport à ça c'est
clairement
c'est une experte en termes de
ça
puis là mettons aujourd'hui que tu avais
une rencontre avec la Ville de Laval
est-ce que est-ce que tu te sens est-ce
que tu sens que ton expertise et écouter
mettons au niveau politique est-ce que
est-ce que tu sens que tu as un réel à
part ou bien le jeu politique est trop
puissant pour prendre en considération
les opinions les autres moi en fait
de 1 je travaille avec ceux qui veulent
travailler
j'espère j'essaie de pas dépenser mon
énergie avec des personnes
de mauvaise foi ou qu'ils ont déjà leur
opinion de fête
comme je sais pas quelqu'un qui aime la
controverse ou le stage je suis
quelqu'un de CG on a tous autant
d'énergie pas tant de temps on peut tuer
si ça fait partie de la boucle oui
dans le fond
moi c'est quand j'interviens dans les
médias quand je travaille avec vous
quand c'est pas l'individu c'est là
c'est la personne qui écoute moi je m'en
fous l'animateur c'est la personne qui
m'écoute je préfère faire des entrevues
à Moret le matin Radio X que radcan à la
limite
des gens ils peuvent dire puis j'ai dit
j'avais déjà eu cette discussion là avec
un collègue Raphaël Jacob on a fait
notre doctorat ensemble lui est un tempo
mais en Sciences Po c'est le qu'on s'est
connu puis il fait des médias il fait
des médias partout là il fait des médias
dans la radio privée public tout ça
les gens ils voient ça de manière
péjorative l'autre parler au grand
public mais je m'excuse mais le monde
c'est ceux qui écoutent ok fait que si
tu veux avoir un minimum d'influence
puis parler au vrai monde c'est là ça se
passe c'est pas tour d'ivoire là tu sens
que tu as plus d'impact justement en
parlant au public et en influence
finalement le pignon public que avec les
avec les trucs sont au top moi mon
interlocuteur là c'est mes étudiants et
le public moi je payais par le
gouvernement c'est en tant que
professeur d'université publique
c'est sûr que Lena est un partenaire
privilégié du gouvernement avec des fois
on peut avoir des mandats de conseils
pour t’élever on peut avoir des mandats
de conseils pour le gouvernement on peut
former les gens dans l'administration
mais moi je mon interlocuteur si jamais
le politicien
c'est pas tant le politicien c'est pas
eux que je tente de convaincre c'est les
gens qui les mettent
puis j'ai pas de
petits affaires disent le quotidien le
temple de la foi
même personne qui dit
la grenouille dans l'eau chaude à mort
et quotidien elle tente de la foi ouais
non mais
c'est 30 secondes pour que ça signe
dis-moi ce que tu fais toutes les jours
puis je vais dire c'est quoi le grain
Uptown que tu fais là
un courriel à la fois
publication à la fois une entrevue à la
fois
j'ai pas investi de mission
travail
le laisser non plus j'essaie d'avoir une
vie personnelle et sociale et familiale
normale donc il faut un équilibre mais
non
mon interlocuteur
merci beaucoup
de croiser sur la ligne qui n'aura pas
lieu d'être à moi sur
un élève ou à vélo sur la nouvelle voie
vélo de chemin Sainte-Foy